c'est la route qu'il faut défendre à
tout prix un axe aujourd'hui désertées
par les civils mais que l'armée
ukrainienne a tient pour l'instant
et voici crasse nos piles ya le village
verrous face à l'avancée des russes ils
sont plus au nord à moins de 10 kg mais
il chante ce artillerie quasi permanent
et tensions chez ces secouristes
je suis désolé c'est très chaud là je ne
peux pas vous parler
c'est en effet une course contre la
montre
ces hommes attendaient deux blessés en
provenance du front
les voici dont sept ans de lens blindés
les forces je craignais ne concède
qu'elles perdent du terrain dans cette
zone
l'armée russe a avancé de 7 km ces
derniers jours ces images illustrent ces
difficultés
l'un des deux hommes est grièvement
blessé
sur cette route de nombreux checkpoints
et obstacles antichar
prendre cette région du dombass est
désormais l'objectif prioritaire de
vladimir poutine mais malgré leurs
difficultés ses soldats ne doute pas un
instant
pour l'instant nous regroupons nous
troupes dans cette région tous les deux
jours nous avons de nouveaux jeunes qui
arrivent
nous allons défendre ces territoires et
faire reculer les russes
[Musique]
à quelques kilomètres cela violence qu
la ville que veut prendre moscou elle
est sous alerte aérienne permanente
ces bus arrive de village lourdement
bombardé des civils terrorisés et hagard
qui espère prendre un train pour sortir
de cette région menacée
autant de choses que tu me sembles nous
devons sauver nos vies à belge après on
reviendra et tout sera comme invendables
[Musique]
un théâtre de combats que tous les
civils sont invités à évacuer
une armée ukrainienne très clairement
sous pression et qui perd du terrain
dans cette région du dombass d'ailleurs
l'armée ukrainienne renforce toutes ses
positions le long de cette route qui
mène vers risoul cette ville tenue par
les russes depuis le 1er avril